it may look like the cast of 2018's
Aquaman is really swimming underwater
but in reality the set was 100 dry
instead of swimming actors were strapped
into tuning forks and these tracking
markers those were for CG hair that
flows with the current
underwater scenes Force filmmakers to
rethink every aspect of production from
details like stubble on stunt doubles to
something as basic as whether the actors
are going to get wet the first option
for shooting underwater scenes is to
film in an actual body of water
there's nothing better than the real
thing but it's no easy task
1916's 20 000 Leagues Under the Sea was
the first feature film to shoot
underwater but underwater cameras didn't
even exist yet so they had to use a
series of interlocking tubes created for
deep sea Dives and retrofitted for
underwater photography with a glass orb
known as a photosphere by the time
Disney's 1954 remake of the same name
came out some technological advancements
made shooting underwater much easier but
still limited underwater housing made
cameras waterproof and custom-made
diving suits gave the actors an hour of
oxygen before they had to go up for air
today it's even easier to shoot in Open
Water thanks to more technological
advancements like this hidden breathing
apparatus
but working in the ocean is still
unpredictable for example in 2016's the
shallows the water was too rough to keep
this rock in place despite it being tied
down by several tons of cement since the
sea is so unpredictable filmmakers May
opt for a different option that requires
little to no water at all a technique
called dry for wet like for 1981s For
Your Eyes Only The Crew used wind
machines to blow the cast's hair while
running the camera at 120 frames per
second to mimic the slowness of
underwater movements and to get these
bubbles they actually placed glass fish
tanks in front of the camera this water
tank effect was also used in 2017's
Pirates of the Caribbean Dead Men tell
no Tales to create light ripples
the crew built an overhead lighting rig
and placed a bucket of water under each
light when the lights flashed on top of
the water those ripples that reflected
onto the artificial ocean floor
to create swimming motions Crews often
hoist actors up on wires and tuning
Forks underwater qualities can also be
added with CG which requires careful
attention to detail like hair
in Aquaman the actors wore tracking
marks on the backs of their heads wavy
CG hair could then easily be added to
Dolph Lundgren Patrick Wilson and Amber
heard's heads as they swam but
filmmakers can only do so much to
recreate the nuances of an underwater
environment so how do they get realistic
water without the burdens of an open
ocean
water tanks
shooting in a tank adds real water to
the screen while allowing for nearly
complete control over the element's
temperature roughness and clarity
but working with real water means the
approach to set design has to be
completely reimagined for example 13
lives portrays The Tam luang cave rescue
the real underwater caves were
incredibly narrow and intricate with
four levels to recreate the specific
environments and water qualities the
crew built each level as a unique set in
its own pool they built the tunnels in
16 foot sections and then used a crane
to lift the pieces into the empty tanks
only after all the sets were fully built
out did the tank get enclosed and filled
with water set designers have to rethink
how to build these sets typical
materials like wood and plaster are a
no-go it doesn't survive being
underwater and deteriorates extremely
rapidly within the die production
designer Molly Hughes constructed these
caves out of welding wire frames that
she then covered in concrete for even
more control
choosing the right materials is trickier
when a set is either partially submerged
or floods during the scene
Molly made some of the stalactites and
rocks out of foam she had to coat those
pieces in concrete and then bolt them to
the floors and walls any pieces that
would be submerged were given Extra Care
Molly added orange red streaks in these
underwater rocks for this moment when
they're illuminated by one of The
Rescuers headlamps and all these areas
were covered with waterproof sealant so
the paint wouldn't fade too quickly
another benefit of using a tank is the
ability to add a filtration system so
the camera captures clear images but
having a murky element is actually much
more realistic so just like with the
water elements in those dry for wet
scenes the murky effect had to be added
after filming and an even simpler way to
make a tank look like Open Water film
lots of close-ups it's the closer you
are to someone the less particulate
there is between the subject and the
lens with these three methods at their
disposal Productions May opt to use a
combination while the mag features lots
of epic shots from a water tank stunt
performer Shane Bell estimates that 70
percent of it was filmed out in the open
ocean the shallows was also shot in
tanks and the ocean which meant figuring
out how to get the water to look
consistent so underwater cinematographer
Simon christidis matched the two bodies
of water through color grading we're in
the tank we can turn the water blue or
green now we can adjust the color of the
water but what we can't adjust is the
visibility
now that we know where underwater seams
get shot what about the people shooting
them and acting in them figuring out
which camera to use isn't as simple as
taking a GoPro into a tank with you when
Simon worked on the shallows for example
he chose both his camera and Equipment
based on water conditions and depth
there's different tools for different
parts of the water instead of having
like a roller paintbrush I have a range
of brushes to use the deeper he goes
underwater the heavier his equipment
will be so when he had to shoot Blake
Lively or the shark under the surface he
put his camera housing on a Seabob an
underwater jet that also helped Propel
the shark head used for VFX reference
it's basically an underwater jet and
they are so fast the large camera
allowed for smoother and steadier shots
but this heavy setup wouldn't work for
shots that transition from out of the
water to under the surface like this one
Simon instead attached a lightweight
camera to a crane capable of going
underwater we can be above water
following her and then we can dip it
under the water up to about two meters
and then we can pull it back out again
specific underwater sets can limit
camera choice in 13 lives the actors had
to squeeze through tight underwater
tunnels so it would have been
challenging to use a camera as big as
the one he used in the shallows so he
utilized sleeker and smaller camera
housing like in these POV shots
Simon gave the actors mini cameras to
hold as they squeezed through the
cameras were attached to these small
handles to eliminate any shakiness
and when it came to the tunnels in 13
lives he knew the space was so narrow
that his feet would be touching the
ground so instead of fins he wore these
rubber shoes so he could move smoothly
while carrying his camera housing
while Simon wears diving gear behind the
camera the performers in front of the
camera need to be in costume and these
costumes also need to hold up to the
rigors of underwater filmmaking take
this scene from 2017's Kong Skull Island
because Brie Larson falls into the water
she's wearing her normal clothes
including these heavy boots which
prevented her from lying completely flat
while sinking so Shane said they lined
Breeze boots with foam to make them
lighter and more buoyant costumes can be
even more of a nuisance when a character
is swimming underwater like the rock had
to do in 2015 San Andreas the heavier
the clothes the more energy and oxygen
you use trying to swim you can't really
use your feet to kind of
swim around you got to use your legs as
a whole so you're using your legs as a
whole like your breasts doing
breaststroke you try to push you along
or you're using your arms to grab things
to pull you along because he wasn't
connected to any Oxygen The Rock had to
do short takes while holding his breath
compare that to this underwater moment
and extraction thanks to a much lighter
outfit the actor could hold his breath
for up to three minutes costume
designers also have to keep in mind how
the costumes look both in and out of the
water in 2022's Black Panther wakanda
forever Lupita nyong'o's submersible
suit was made with a bioluminescent
material so the colors would come across
underwater because of that Sheen Lupita
said the costume never looked wet
meaning she could do multiple takes in
the same outfit
every tiny detail needs to be thought
through even the facial hair on a stunt
double like when Shane had to match
Jason Statham's look when doubling for
him on the Meg the makeup team couldn't
glue fakes double to his face like they
normally would as it would come off in
the water so instead they applied a 3D
transfer tattoo of stubble to his face
making is already a feat of
detail-oriented work when you add water
it multiplies everything that works for
dry scenes no longer applies and no
matter how much you prepare so so you've
got to kind of figure out the bits and
make those decisions on the day
sometimes so everything's very easy
above water for me
[Music]